voici maintenant un couple exceptionnel
de la chanson céline dion et jean
jacques goldman qui sont associés pour
un nouvel album de 12 titres signés
goldman céline dion et jean jacques
goldman avait déjà travaillé ensemble en
1996 cette fois-ci l'album s'intitule
s'il suffisait d'aimer et pendant qu à
chanteuse québécoise est en tournée aux
états unis
jean jacques goldman s'est confiée à
louis carzou et jean-françois chevet
lorsqu'il revient au studio méga près de
paris jean jacques goldman se laisserait
presque aller à 3 note de nostalgie
c'est ici qu'il a réussi à retrouver
l'une de ses interprètes préférés
céline dion
réussi car depuis leur premier disque la
québécoise est passé par la case titanic
et quand on a vendu une chanson à 23
millions d'exemplaires le principal
problème devient l'emploi du temps
non détenus
oui
jacques m'a présenté des chansons et
évidemment ça a été ça a été un grand
grand coup de foudre et gt2 de savoir
que je te pour retravailler avec
jean-jacques à nouveau donc au mois
d'avril on s'est revus pour
l'enregistrement du disque et à
l'intérêt d'une semaine on a tout fait
juste deux trois sets par soir
moi je me sens dans la situation d'un
auteur compositeur à qui on donne une
voix exceptionnelle que n'importe quel
auteur compositeur souhaite avoir
c'est un rêve un rêve pour le moins
récurrents la dernière fois que jean
jacques goldman et céline dion ont
partagé leur emploi du temps
ils étaient plus de 11 millions à se
laisser bercer par leur partition
oui